a procession honoring fallen soldiers
this year tens of thousands have climbed
the steps of this memorial in
jingangshan in southern china
the town is called the cradle of the
revolution and was where chinese
communist party founder mao zedong
escaped opposition kuomintang forces and
expanded his embattled red army
in the lead-up to the party's 100-year
anniversary visitors have come to pay
their respects to mao
and his comrades i'm here because i love
the motherland
i love the communist party i've
witnessed our country develop
and become stronger
[Music]
the chinese communist party was founded
in 1921
with only a few dozen members today
there are more than 90 million
the body has ruled china unopposed since
1949
and from the bottom to the top all are
affirming their loyalty to the party
ahead of july the firsts
president xi jinping has called on all
sectors of society to promote the
party's history and ideology
in the lead-up to the celebration the
communists not only helped
china to rise up and the chinese people
to become strong
and prosperous eventually but they also
instilled a nation building and
national awareness in the minds of the
chinese people they realize that
the chinese people are no longer weak or
enfeebled
for months this has been reflected in
everything from communist party trivia
game shows
to television dramas under president xi
jinping the communist party has combined
marxism
with capitalism authoritarianism and
even traditional confucius ideals
but its core message remains the same
that this
represents strength and order while the
west
represents chaos beijing has highlighted
the importance of so-called
patriotic education to cultivate a new
generation of party followers
but their textbooks won't include
historic failures
such as the calamitous famine of the
1960s
or the 1989 crackdown following the
tiananmen square protests
only achievements are marked the
economic growth which lifted millions
out of poverty
the containment of the coronavirus
outbreak within months
they have succeeded but you're if you're
only as good as your successes
you have no escape valve there's no
pressure relief
you constantly have to deliver and that
puts a tremendous
amount of pressure on the on the party
that pressure is being felt by china's
security agencies
which are doing all they can to ensure
1.4 billion people
fall into line under one flag and one
party katrina you al jazeera jinganjan
china